so let me bring us all back together
uh i was at this point in in my lesson
plan
i was just going to tell you the answer
and get a bit of a discussion going
and then i just it just dawned on me in
the last 30 seconds that
it'll be much more fun if i don't do
that yet
so i'm going to come back to that puzzle
we are all going to return to it but
here's the thing i want to get to all of
you and this is kind of um we're now
please if you haven't already pick up
your pen um if you haven't made a
heading you can call it
introduction to the nature of proof
because that's what we're doing right
now
and i want to try and get into the weeds
of
how it is that we prove things in
mathematics because you've actually been
doing this
for years and years and years but we've
not as it were
looked underneath the hood of the car
you've been driving for a long time and
you've
gone places but you haven't necessarily
looked at how an internal combustion
engine
works um that's what proof is in
mathematics it's the engine
so we're going to start to look at the
mechanics of how it works um and
importantly i want to give you some
language i'm going to actually give you
a lot of language
to understand what it is that you just
did
and how it actually functions so the
basic building block that we're going to
talk about here
is a statement and statements are
you know they have a technical meaning
uh in mathematics that they don't have
in
you know broader english uh just like a
word like
acceleration means something specific in
mathematics and physics
uh a change in velocity which it you
know usually would say oh it just means
go fast stuff right
so in mathematics a statement is
something that can be
um it can take a binary value a binary
logical value it's true
or it's false can't be both um
and it can't be neither okay so it's one
or the other
now as you were trying to solve this
right and um
you know discussing with people around
you you were making statements
some of them were true and importantly
very very importantly
you were also making false statements
you had to make some false statements to
try and sift out
what you actually knew was true
right so just let me give you some
examples because we've been working with
these for quite some time right
these statements right can have many
different categories so
the most common one that you've been
dealing with for years and years is
statements
that we know whether they're true or
false okay so here are a couple of
examples right
so obviously in mathematics we we try
and use symbols wherever we can because
it's more efficient
right rather than using words but
sometimes you just have to go to words
which we'll do a lot in this topic
but these are two statements here one's
true one's false and we know
we know that these are true right
there are some statements that their
truth actually will change
depending on some kind of condition
right so every time that you've ever
written
an inequality you made a conditional
statement okay this is true
sometimes it's true sometimes right um
i could say by the way it's not just an
inequality equations can often be true
on conditions if i just replace that
greater than or equal sign with an equal
sign
2x minus 5 doesn't always equal 4 it
only equals 4
for a certain value of x we would call
that its solution
right so there are certain conditions on
certain statements
some statements we actually don't know
they may be true
they may not be true but we haven't
actually gotten to the bottom of this so
a famous one
um which is called the twin prime
conjecture
is that you guys know what prime numbers
are
we know that prime numbers uh except for
two
they can't be even so the closest they
can ever be to
each other is is two apart so as an
example 17 and 19
are as close together as any primes can
get
we're just excluding two it's called the
trivial result so twin primes are primes
like 17 and 19 that are like right next
to each other
right are there infinitely many of those
as numbers get bigger and bigger and
bigger like the primes start to
thin out as your numbers get larger but
do you keep getting these do you keep
getting like
17s and 19s beside each other we don't
know
so this is the twin prime conjecture
it's going to be true or false but we
just don't know which one okay
now sometimes we just we just declare
things to be true we assert
that they are true so that's you know
most times when you say
let something happen in your um
mathematical proof
what you're doing is you're asserting
something a statement uh it may or may
not be true just like every other
statement
but generally you have kept within the
domain of
saying things that are true and then you
can draw true conclusions off of them
now um there's one last important
category that i'm going to include here
which you might remember from
mathematical induction which you
did last term right in mathematical
induction part of the point is sometimes
you make statements
that are not quite any of these right
and that's part of the heart it's uh
it's step two of when you're doing a
proof by induction it's not a you
introduce a statement
it's not known it's not conditional it's
not unknown it's not asserted it's
starts with an a do you remember it's
assumed right you're like
here's a statement i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna pretend
that it's true for a little while and
then i'm gonna use that as a foundation
to build on and then see what happens
right and by the way these last two they
often fit together so a famous one of
these um sorry not these last two
um this one and the the middle one we
often have some things that we don't
know true but we're like so close to
being
confident that we just kind of assume it
and run with it so a really famous one
is called i'll write it down for you
because it's
such a big deal it's called the
it's probably the most famous um
unsolved unknown
mathematics problem um today it's called
the riemann hypothesis named after the
german mathematician bernhard riemann
and it's a really really crazy result we
don't know whether it's true or not
we've been wrestling with it for a long
time
but it's been checked to like so many
trillions of values that we're like
we think it's true and a lot of modern
mathematics and physics is actually
built
on the fact we just assumed that it's
true we just run with it right a lot of
quantum physics in particular so
sometimes we just assume things to be
true and that can still be useful even
if they're unknown
okay so
we've got these kinds of things right um
we can say we know that these are true
right
so i can string these together and
create what we call
a mathematical proof and i'm going to
let this sort of sit here for a moment
because i'm going to use this as my
skeleton my framework for returning to
this puzzle about truth
tellers and liars so i'm just going to
leave this here for a minute and talk
through it so that you can actually
write it down because everything that's
here
i'd like you to have um on your page
because we're going to refer back to
these
over and over again so if we're already
talking about statements
a synonym for statement is a claim right
so it's like i claim that this is true
uh we often will write something like oh
triangle abc is equilateral and
mathematicians their language that is i
claim that this triangle has you know is
an equilateral all the sides all the
angles
are equal to each other so statements
synonymous with claims
now you can't just say oh um something
is true in mathematics
we ask for reasoning we ask for a backup
for like but why would you
believe that so we call that
substantiation can you substantiate
those claims that's also a legal word
right in a court of law
it's like yeah you claim that my my uh
my client
is guilty but what's your substantiation
for that give me your evidence okay so
that's another good
synonym for this which i probably should
have written down substantiation of
those claims the reasoning
the evidence for that is why we think or
accept these things are true
and then lastly we need kind of a thread
that forms a coherent
argument right one of the you guys know
you've listened to
um you've written essays and you've
listened to you know public speakers and
debaters
if there is not a sequence of logic that
joins all of the statements
then it's a very unconvincing argument
so often
for example one of our favorite logical
connectors is this one
this of course means therefore right
it's like
immediately following from this
statement and substantiation i made
i can draw this conclusion right um but
that's not the only one sometimes you
might say
what right it's like i've made something
and now i'm going to say a contrast like
the opposite of
therefore in a way so that sequence is
really
important if you don't have that thread
all the way through
then you're in some real trouble okay so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
switch over some technology here but
i want to return as promised to this
puzzle and see how we can make some
statements
some substantiation for those statements
and then sort of thread them all
together
in a sequence of logic that will
convince all of you because it was great
i was listening to people
arguing about this and saying no this
has to be true or this has to be false
and other people being completely
unconvinced so
that's what we're going to try and do
right now
just as i switch over technology i want
you to return to where you were taking
some notes potentially
on this or maybe you didn't take any
notes on this puzzle at all i want you
to see if you can start to articulate
like and you can write
i haven't given you any framework or any
specific terminology how would you write
not just say but how would you write an
argument for convincing yourself of
who's telling the truth and who's lying
okay
i'll give you about a minute to do that
while i just switch over my bits and
bobs here